okay so earlier on the on in the show I
told you about the claims that John
Bolton makes in his book Donald Trump
okaying
Chinese concentration camps Trump saying
invading Venezuela would be cool Trump
asking China for help getting reelected
a trump saying reporters should be
imprisoned or executed Trump didn't know
that the UK had nuclear weapons on and
on and on we did that earlier in the
show I then told you about the legal
battle by Trump's Justice Department to
suppress the publication of John
Bolton's book including a footnote
provision that is asking courts to ban
bookstores from selling Bolton's book
under threat of punishment or legal
action so we already did all of that
stuff now I want to talk about Donald
Trump's reaction Donald Trump
predictably was so triggered by what is
in John Bolton's book that he absolutely
exploded both on television and on
Twitter it's been going for almost 24
hours now we just had to add more tweets
to this story because Trump just won't
stop tweeting so here is Trump kicking
it off last night with sean hannity
foxnews propagandists total total
disinformation whitewashing attempt of
of the entire story calling bolton a
washed-up criminal let's take a look at
this clip and then in terms of bolton he
broke the law he was a washed up guy i
gave him a chance
he couldn't get senate confirmed so I
gave him an on Senate confirmed position
where I could just put him there see how
he worked and I wasn't very enamored he
went into the Middle East he was one of
the the big guns for let's go into Iraq
and that didn't work out too well that I
was against that a long time ago before
I was ever even thinking about doing
what I'm doing now but he was one of the
people wanted to go to Iraq when I asked
him about it I said recently I said you
know about a month in when he was about
a month in I said what do you think you
think you made a mistake there no I
don't think so I don't think so I said
explain that one so though terrible
terrible things that he did but he broke
the law very simple I mean as much as
it's going to be broke if this is highly
classified that's the highest sage it's
highly classified information that he
did not have approval so on they said
this is amazing
Trump says both that Bolton's claims are
lies and that they're classified if
they're lies how are they classified its
made-up stuff right it just doesn't make
any sense
and Trump's also funny because he says
Bolton was bad because he went into Iraq
and Trump hired him fifteen years later
knowing that doesn't Trump say he hires
the best people so Trump making no sense
if it's lies how are they classified if
you hire the best people why did you
hire someone that is so terrible and
then the real triggering Trump clearly
sitting there fermenting with his phone
tweet after embarrassing tweet and I
want to look at a couple of these with
you Donald Trump retweeting right-wing
disinformation propagator Dinesh D'Souza
who attacked Bolton Donald Trump adding
to D'Souza's tweet President Bush fired
him also Bolton is incompetent Trump
calling Bolton a wacko and a dope
tweeting quote whacko but John Bolton's
exceedingly tedious book is made up of
Lies and fake stories said all good
about me in print until the day I fired
him a disgruntled boring fool who only
wanted to go to war never had a clue was
ostracized and happily dumped what a
dope and I go back again if they're lies
how is it a problem that
Bolton is publishing classified
information if he's making it all up it
by definition couldn't be classified
because it doesn't really exist right
Trump kept going this morning completely
out of control saying quote Bolton's
book which is getting terrible reviews
is a compilation of Lies and made-up
stories
all intended to make me look bad many of
the ridiculous statements he attributes
to me were never made pure fiction just
trying to get even for firing him like
the sick puppy he is and again if it's
all lies why are you suppressing it on
the basis of it being classified and
then
- series to tweet series where he says
quote when Wakko John Bolton went on to
face the nation and so stupidly said
that he looked at the Libyan model for
North Korea all hell broke out Kim
jong-un who we were getting along with
very well went ballistic just like his
missiles and rightfully so he didn't
want Bolton anywhere near him
Bolton's dumbest of all statements set
us back very badly with North Korea even
now I asked him what the hell were you
thinking he had no answer and just
apologized that was early on I should
have fired him right then and there now
we could do an hour on Trump with North
Korea and his delusions the real problem
with North Korea was Trump falling for
the same stuff that North Korean leaders
have been doing and saying for 30 years
Trump's actually believed it right other
presidents both Democrat and Republican
knew that they shouldn't fall for the
idiotic and unbelievable claims from
North Korean leaders Trump fell for them
so Trump thought he was making progress
so I mean I don't even know where where
to start all of this right Fox's
position has been to get experts on
saying Bolton's book in dangers our
national security by putting out
classified and secret information well
Trump says it's all lies so how can lies
be secret and classified at the same
time the real risk to our national
security all along has been Donald Trump
remember Trump once tweeted what should
have been a classified and remained
classified satellite photo national
security means nothing to Trump Trump
once had a meeting with Russians in the
Oval Office and shared Israeli
intelligence with them which he had not
been given the okay to share which
endangered an actual important source of
information about Isis for example which
Donald Trump claimed to be fighting very
very strongly about so if you want to
talk about endangering national security
and playing fast and loose with what
should be secret and classified
information and I say should because I
understand legally Trump can declassify
whatever he wants doesn't mean it's
smart or prudent to do it real
it's Trump we need to be looking at and
again I have a tweet about this which
you can look at I'm Deepak Minh on
Twitter how is it that Trump is furious
that Bolton is both lying but that what
he writes in the book is classified
information if they are lies it doesn't
exist it's made up and therefore being
classified wouldn't actually be a
problem I'm sure that the trumpets will
find some way to excuse that completely
incoherent claim but it is not making
too much sense now let's dig in I've
been building to this Bolton deserves
huge criticism for what he did to some
degree and that's where we're going to
go next if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blinka stinkiest lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video